[Music]
Jordan
[Music]
when you want to turn a situation around
or raise the stakes in an already tense
anime moment there are a few better ways
to do it than with an epic entrance or
maybe you just want a cool scene for a
character to establish themselves and
give everyone a memorable moment either
way anime gives us some of the best
entrances we can see from TV series so
it's with pleasure that I'll share what
I think are the best anime entrances
from 2022 now these moments will be
Loosely ranked as in I won't be putting
a hard designation on ordering them but
I lean towards putting my favorite ones
near to the end so stay tuned we start
off with something from spriggan
yo
now
there's barely any Buzz for spriggan
even when it was airing and that's all
to be expected I guess given the nature
of the show and its release schedule
however that also means that a lot of
you are likely to have seen this
entrance by Jean Jackman you finds
himself in quite the troubling situation
in this episode of spriggan even the
strongest agents find their match
someday and this seems to be the battle
to push you to his limits forcing him to
release his true Powers however today's
not that day and that's all thanks to
Jean's badass entrance appearing from
high above Sean wastes no time trash
talking his eventual partner and rival
as he just stands there looking cool and
asserting his dominance it's a pretty
good way to introduce a character
establish his abrasive personality and
build some hype for him it's simple but
it's one of the scenes that makes you
want to see more of what jean can do
have some spy family now with this your
moment
[Music]
there are many things to love about spy
family the comedy is very wholesome and
genuine the character interactions are
great and while it's mostly comedy is
the type that you can easily put on and
have a good time with the family even
non-anime fans too and then there are
some moments while having comedic
undertones are also heartwarming and
awesome at the same time you're saving
Anya by going full Spider-Man before
turning those villains into pinballs is
one of those such moments and despite
all the light-hearted lines and reaction
that delivered in a way that can be seen
as over the top it's a very wholesome
scene that shows the love she has for
this makeshift family
thank you
[Music]
we proceed with Mirko making her
presence felt
this Arc is just full of explosively
cool moments of course no one can forget
shigaraki's Awakening and the sheer
amount of anticipation and hype his
Newfound power generated but how about
the hero's Invasion to the hospital
preceding that moment like America's
short but sweet entrance crashing into
kudai's lab and sending true fear Into
the Heart of the doctor judai's
expression is all you need to know about
this scene with Miracle's confidence
combined with kudai knowing that he's a
hundred percent screwed this is such a
fun way to end the episode and the good
news is that it's only the beginning of
a long sequence that remains one of my
favorite ones from my hero Academia so
far my hero Academia has been
consistently cool and exciting the
things have really turned up a notch
this season and it's only going to get
better from here on out
using the fox devil is something a
little bit different
cool
when we talk about entrances they're
usually something grandiose something
that comes with music or at least with
insane Feats or voice acting or
something like that but this one's
probably the simplest and snappiest if
you will amongst the entries I've
covered on this channel before when
denji finds himself in big trouble you
have Aki just being all chill or
composed and quickly summoning the fox
devil con what's that then bam this fox
demon thing comes out and instantly puts
an end to the devil giving denji a run
for his money it's quick gives no time
for anyone even in Universe to react
barely qualifies as an entrance in the
traditional sense of the word but it
does get the job done nobody saw it
coming when Aki made that hand sign to
signify something awesome was coming
instead of a grand summoning spell or
something like that everything's just
over just like that
here we are with a video break with me
asking you for some likes and
subscriptions please likes and
subscriptions are the best way for you
to show your appreciation and help the
channel grow so if you've been enjoying
what you've seen so far please make sure
you do those Arc saves a princess in
this next cool entrance
now this is a scene that I admit can be
a tad bit controversial it's got the
makings of something that looks like it
came out of that notorious scene from
Goblin Slayer minus the more Brazen
nature of that scene of course it's
something that light novel anime have
employed quite often and in a way it
does serve its purpose of giving the
inevitable hero entrance much more
impact after all entrances are best done
in the bleakest moments an arc makes
such an imposing figure when he finally
appears to serve righteous Justice
against these evil doers the scene
really makes the audience feel the anger
towards these bad guys and justifies Ark
just effortlessly cutting these people
apart without any fuss with any words he
just comes in to deliver Poetic Justice
it's a simple entrance but it's one that
struck me for several reasons I'd say
that the anime team did get their job
done in terms of animating this scene
and evoking the right emotions
foreign
back at it again this time saving Jolin
in stone ocean
[Music]
just when he thought it was all over for
Jolene jotaro swoops in and easily shows
that he's still got more left in the
tank and did you see this coming when
Pucci had our heroes in a pinch and
fired those lethal shots who better to
save Jolin than jotaro himself I can't
be the only one who got goosebumps when
time stopped and that iconic music
started right all that before star
Platinum comes in and delivers one of
the most satisfying anime punches in the
series The anime team really nailed the
scene and any JoJo fan can't help but
get up and cheer when this all
transpired it's such a beautiful
entrance and it makes for a much
appreciated reunion both between jotaro
and Jolin as well as between jotaro and
the numerous JoJo fans who followed him
on his adventures through the years
Demon Slayer continues to impress so
here have a tangent entrance
among the numerous pillars tanjiro has
had the pleasure of fighting alongside
so far I think that tengen is the one
who got the short end of the stick well
at first he does make a good impression
but in terms of powers and feet he
doesn't get to do much at the start and
spends much of the early part keeping a
low profile it doesn't take too long for
all that to change when he finally steps
in to save his wives appearing in the
underground Cavern to provide help he
makes short work of the Obi the Swift
and precise way he cuts down the OB is
one thing what I like about the entrance
is how it was built up in just a short
period of time there are only a few
lines of the OB wondering about the
Intruder before the sense of wonder
turns into fear as the realization then
starts to creep in this is a pillar in
the flesh more than a match for any
non-moon demons the ass kicking
afterwards which even extends to [ __ ]
moving forward is just the icing on the
cake Tangen sure is the pillar who knows
how to make the most stylish entrances
well we got intimidating Whimsical and
bombastic entrances from other pillars
tengen is the one who gets the most
points for combining the sleek and
badass appeal of a pillar together in
this signature way
in Luffy's amazing entrance in episode
1015
[Music]
with the grand battle against the
alliance of kaido and big mom in full
swing time for Our Heroes to make their
entrance and Luffy couldn't have done it
any better emerging from the smoke he
carries with him a disposition that
looks more like a cool stoic light novel
hero than the Luffy we've known from the
2000s and actually even the 2010s the
narration also helps out a lot with the
hype as this is the scene with Odin
cutting out it's not too often you see
the hero walk towards two Powerhouse
villains with this much Swagger but our
boy Luffy he slays it in this scene a
boy's grown so much and it's this fight
which encapsulates everything that he's
been through or the challenges the
adventures they come to a head in the
imminent battle and this is such an
awesome way to get everyone hyped for
what's already Beed and extremely
anticipated fight
[Music]
how about Aaron's appearance in the
rumbling
foreign
it's been a roller coaster with the
character and his climactic Arc in this
last stretch of Attack on Titan deserves
nothing less than this bone-chilling
entrance I suppose that he wrote Heralds
the end of the world appearing in this
form though I guess I just can't
describe in words the founding Titan is
nothing like we've seen before and it's
awe-inspiring the reaction towards
seeing his final form is what anyone
would do faced with such an overwhelming
foe leading an army of Doomsday Titans
it's an entrance that really drives home
the fact that resistance is futile such
a beautiful and ominous entrance that
gets me extremely excited for the end of
it all even if you're a manga reader and
already got spoiled on the next scenes
you can't deny that having this entrance
animated has made the scene a thousand
times better
foreign
I'll be finishing with the Quincy
entrance in Bleach Thousand-Year blood
War
s
I was kind of debating on which bleach
entry to put on this list because
Yamamoto had one scorching hot entrance
the moment he joined the Fray but I
decided in the end how about giving the
Quincy some credit hey there isn't a lot
of better ways I could think of for this
group of villains to mark their presence
in the story than this so how did these
people get through Soul society's top
tier defenses by just appearing out of
nowhere quite literally pillars of light
ominous music foreboding presence and
the sudden shootdown of the first few
Defenders the Shinigami had no chance
the Quincy's just appeared and they
struck fast and hard it's not every day
we see Soul Society get overwhelmed like
this and the start of an invasion did
such a great job in setting the tone of
the whole Arc this race was an
afterthought in the series prior to this
Arc but what a way to quickly up the
Threat Level this Arc is where things
get real and it's bleach at its darkest
something that both lapsed and loyal
fans have vastly appreciated in this
adaptation
foreign
and we've reached the end of the list as
my list now how does your list look if
you've got another entrance to suggest
then I'm or is and you can reach me
through both the comments section and
the videotube social media channels
which will be posted in the description
box thank you for watching and I hope
you enjoyed this video I'd love to see
you again for the next video so don't
forget to like And subscribe I'll see
you next time